joining us now with a very tough story 8
news now reporter sasha loftis and sasha
were
learning tonight about a dog that died
in this heat
there is still limited information here
but we do have confirmation from metro
that a dog did die in the northeast
valley today due to that extreme heat
we were in that neighborhood or
neighborhood earlier tonight rather
police say this happened in the
northeast valley again officers
responded to a call
that the dog had passed away in this
neighborhood near lake mead and mount
hood
due to those extreme temperatures now
remember as you just heard ted say
the valley hit a record time 109 degrees
today
no word from authorities on what kind of
dog this was or if any charges will be
filed here
we are expected to receive updates from
clark county animal control in the
coming days
nevada law states you are required to
provide an animal with adequate shade
and water in extreme heat like this if
you see an animal in distress
in the heat call 311 or even local
rescue groups to report it
denise